m toys tom holland back to school season
action figure 129
now the only thing is here this is a bit
creepy for me because this is not a
spider-man doll this is just me this
means that someone has just got a doll
of me in their house and i don't like it
hey what's up guys it's tom holland here
i'm about to do gq's shopping spree
let's go
we're going on a trip on our favorite
rocket ship
[Music]
okay so the first category is snacks
so let's do this okay the first one is
is auntie's spotted dicks now that is a
bit of me put it in the microwave bit of
custard maybe if you're feeling saucy i
love spotted dick and the fact that it's
your aunties makes it feel homemade i
like that i'd buy that our next one is
cricket bites five pack of assorted
flavored
edible
insects
like actual insects
i've actually eaten insects before in
thailand and they were delicious and
they're full of protein yeah look six
grams of protein i would buy those i
would absolutely eat those they're full
of amino acids great for building muscle
yeah
i'd go for the cricket bites i wouldn't
go for cheesy ranch though buffalo wing
sauce yeah spicy cayenne peppers but
definitely not cheesy insects moving on
how do i say that mcvidies
mcviddy's milk chocolate hobnobs i'm not
really a biscuit kind of guy it says
here's suitable for vegetarians what
kind of biscuit isn't suitable for
vegetarians
have anyone in here heard of a meat
biscuit no
i don't think they need to advertise it
like that i think that's pretty clear
that it's vegetarian i'm gonna go for a
no on the milk chocolate hobnobs st
eric's crisps sixty dollars designed to
accompany st eric's premium beer i like
that chips are cooked using some of the
mostly ingredients
it seems like they're doing a little bit
too much work
for a crisp they do look nice though
they come in lovely packaging but
imagine if you went to someone's house
and you gave them this beautiful box as
a gift they'd be really excited oh wow
saint eric's what's that a watch maybe
nice set of cutlery could be anything no
it's actually just five crisps you'd be
really disappointed i'd be furious
actually if someone showed up to my
house and gave me this as a gift i'd ask
them to leave but also saint eric's i
would love to try your crisps so if you
feel like sending me some that would be
great i've just found out i'm only
allowed to pick one okay there's a
budget to this game but because the
snacks are so cheap i'm gonna break the
rules and i'm gonna take
spotted dick is coming home with me the
crickets i'm gonna try them no hob knobs
and i think i'm going to have to try
these saint eric's crisps i'm just going
to have to try them
[Music]
next one sports tickets we're going to
have a look at some sporting events
2022 super bowl starting at 50 000 is
that how much it costs to go to the
super bowl fifty thousand dollars
i don't really know that much about
american football i don't know the rules
so i think that ticket would be wasted
on me
2022 masters saturday to sunday
6 399
now i would love to go
but the thing is is i've already been
and the time that i went was in the
height of covid
so it was empty so you could walk around
the course we got to see all the players
play
so
if i was to go again
[Music]
it would never be as good as the first
time i went so i think
i've done the masters now i don't think
i'll ever go again
2022 nathan's hot dog eating contest oh
it's for free listen there are starving
kids in the world so you couldn't pay me
to go to this contest so that is a big
no from me wasting food 2022 champions
league final take my money i'm going
that's where i'll be
5 356.88
you get a few tickets does it come with
a few tickets or am i just going by
myself yeah i could buy two tickets i'll
take my brother harry i get another
ticket for sam
gqu's paying for this remember so it
doesn't really matter right cheeky
who would you want to see play in the
champions league final if you could pick
two teams i'd want to see tottenham play
brentford
because tottenham is my team and
brentford is my uncle's team and we
would well probably right now we
wouldn't beat brentford but i fancy our
chances sports tickets summary it's
gonna have to be the champions league
final
that's it that's all i can afford right
now i can't bring everyone that's where
i'll be going
working out's a big part of my life
admittedly i haven't been working out at
all let's get into some workout gear
here we go the normatec recovery
compression pants
549 yeah i could see myself
using one of those you know when i'm
doing the spider-man films i do get
really tired and my legs do really hurt
so it's definitely on the maybe on the
maybe list
the theragun pro
599 i've already got one but it's not a
theragun it's a different one i like it
but maybe the theragun's better who
knows this one has a little screen on it
it looks like so it can tell you how
hard it's
punching you the agata rower 2
1999
now rowing machine is an excellent way
of getting cardio in it works the whole
upper body it works your legs it works
your calves i think it's an excellent
piece of kit so i'm going to put that on
the maybe list i like that a lot and it
also looks very nice it's quite tasteful
it has the water in it not the fan so
i'm sure you get the nice sort of
sloshing water sound as you're doing it
which makes you feel like you're rowing
that looks mustard and it's got a screen
on it so maybe a peloton style
rowing machine
is my next purchase
we will see
kangaroo jumping shoes 249
reduces impact on joints and muscles by
up to 80
yeah but in the 80 that you save in your
joints and muscle fibers you lose
because you look like an absolute donut
running around
in these stupid shoes i'm gonna have to
say the kangaroo shoes
are not for me
so as far as gym equipment goes
the summary i'm going to go for
the rowing machine because i think
that'll be great i'd use it a lot and i
think i'd have a lot of fun doing it too
that is added to cars
okay action figures
nice
ml legends avenger iron spider spidey
tom holland six
loose action figure it doesn't look like
me very much but i can appreciate some
attention to detail with the suit we'll
put that on the maybe list marvel
legends avengers game verse spider-man
tom holland far from home figure see
that's weird that they put my face on
the spider-man from the game because i'm
not in the game that's a strange little
multiverse thing going on there i like
that it's cool m toys tom holland back
to school season action figure 129
now the only thing is here this is a bit
creepy for me because this is not a
spider-man doll this is just me this
means that someone has just got a doll
of me in their house and i don't like it
it creeps me out that it comes with a
whole selection of different hands and
sometimes i get jealous the doll's
better looking than i am
that's when you're all supposed to say
no tom
you're way better looking than the doll
funko pops i love funko pops 43 bucks
worth every penny i think they're really
cool i've actually collected all of my
funko pops i kept them in my house for a
long time but then it kind of got to the
point where it looked like i had a
shrine for myself and i had to get rid
of them because it was quite
embarrassing so they're in a cupboard
but i love them and uh keep making them
i think they're brilliant so in summary
i'm gonna go for the funko pop because i
think they're cute and i like them
[Music]
we're going on a trip on our favorite
rocket ship let's do this christmas
japanese snowboarding ski in ski out 51
043
why do they bother with the 43 dollars
what is the 43 getting you
extra is it an extra glass of champagne
upon arrival it's unnecessary
but that said i've heard that skiing or
i snowboard in
japan is one of the best places in the
world to do it they have the best snow i
would love to go i love
japan i love japanese culture i'm always
looking for a reason to go back so this
is probably going to be very high on my
list a yacht festival in croatia
3048
per person seven nights a 45 foot
catamaran ultra festival and 10 people
i'm not sure about that one i guess you
could leave at any time if you're having
a bad time you could just get your boat
and go and leave but that to me just
seems like one of my friends is gonna
drown i'm not a huge fan of that that's
definitely on the no list
a five night western caribbean cruise
from miami with marvel day at sea
five thousand nine hundred and ninety
seven dollars and 34 cents again why 34
cents for two people going on a cruise
is my worst nightmare i've been on one i
had a really good time
but now that my life has changed i don't
think being on a boat where you can't
get off is a good idea okay so trips
away
unfortunately it's gonna have to be the
most expensive one so maybe in the year
of 2022 i'm going to go on holiday once
just really splurge for once you know
i'm really enjoying myself but i'm going
to go to japan i can't wait i'm really
excited thanks gq i can't wait who are
you taking to japan with you
theoretically
who am i taking to japan with me uh
that's none of your business
moving on
we're now going to look at homes so here
we go homes the first one is santropay
modern estate 98 million 573
582
dollars
so it's cheap
12 bed 12 bath 4.6 acre three villas
three black marble swimming pools that's
not a small house hey that's that's this
is a big old house it sounds wonderful i
will say that 98 million is a that's a
lot of money for a house that's far more
money than i think anyone should be
spending on a house
but we'll uh we'll keep it on the list
because remember gq are buying me these
things
right
private island in key largo florida
price upon request so you know this
place is absolutely ridiculously
expensive 10 bed 11 bath 26 acres 10
minute helicopter to south beach
self-sufficient with water electricity
etc i don't like helicopters i'm scared
of them so i'm gonna have to take that
part of it off the list it's gonna have
to be a boat ride for me the next one is
a ranch in colorado i like the idea of
that it's a cool 60 million dollars 5
908.4 acres so slightly bigger so i i
don't think i'm going to buy this ranch
the next one is an english house i like
that it's 1.1 million dollars herbert
road kingston upon thames that's where i
live freehold three four bedrooms
it says three four bedrooms what does
that mean there's a bedroom that could
be a bedroom wrap-around garden that's a
nice feature popular and convenient
location and it's semi-detached i mean
it looks really nice inside kingston's
where i grew up it's where i live i love
it to bits lovely people it's really
good for young people it's great for
schools there's lots to do is this for
sale now this house
i think anyone spending 98 million
dollars on a house or 60 million dollars
on a house is wasting money i think 1.1
million is i think that's a pretty
respectable
price range in today's world especially
in london i'd love to
buy a house for my granny
so she can come and live in kingston so
it's going to have to be the english
house okay skin care
the omnilux contour face now
embarrassingly i actually have one of
these i use it in the morning in the car
ride on the way to work does it do
anything probably not but it makes me
feel good about myself so
yeah 395 dollars i didn't buy it sony
bought it for me thank you sony i don't
think they know they bought it for me it
just went on a list of expenses
the trezor
rare intensive recovery japanese bin
chotan zumi mask five thousand dollars
wow
that's a lot of money for us for a face
mask yeah i'm gonna have to give that a
pass
the benton snail b mask pack twenty
dollars packer10 contains snail
secretion filtrate which is known to
heal the exterior of snails when wounded
it contains bee venom which is effective
in improving skin concerns disease now
one big question is when you extract the
bee venom do you kill the bees probably
right and we need bees bees are the most
important thing on the planet
so i'm gonna have to say no to the snail
[ __ ] and b venom
face mask moving on okay st ives apricot
face sheet i don't need to read any more
i love these things i bring them on
airplanes because airplanes is where
it's really dry and your skin gets dry
and it's always the case that wherever
you're flying as soon as you get off the
plane you have to go to work so i use
those to sleep while i'm on an airplane
so i think i'll probably buy loads of
those of all of the products here
i'd love to try them all
but it's gonna have to be
the saint ives apricot face
so
of my
imaginary allowance i have spent 1.1
million dollars which i actually think
is pretty reasonable you know i've got a
house i've got some really nice snacks
i've got a rowing machine i'm taking my
brothers to the champions league final
i've got some face masks so the flight
over to st petersburg we're gonna have
really nice moist faces which is gonna
be great for the football final
and uh and yeah i'm really glad that i
was quite conservative i didn't go for
the expensive options i went for the
practical options and things that i
actually
would use and i hope you've enjoyed
watching me spend my money
imaginary money